is that even fun having four at once it  seems like a lot of work oh it was it  was not it was not fun it was something  that that was something that you would  make a porn for because you're actually  working yeah it feels like it feels like  you you're not you're worried about four  different women's feelings all at once  and making sure everyone's having  got to have a lot of dick for that like  you have to be a leader  to do it you are a quarterback you have  to you feel me audible audible bend over  turn around eat harass you like line  them up just like ch  no i was more directive like i might  even get some hair like you either [ __ ]  while she giving me head or i might have  two heads on there and they both eat  them the twofer the two first  so maybe you have two sucking your dick  while the other ones are behind each of  them  eating them the play you feel me  yeah it's kind of like human centipede  top of the pyramid  you're the top of the pyramid